à cannes emmanuelle béart a éclipsé hier
soir madonna et c'est justice elle était
encore plus nue que la star américaine
met à l'écran seulement et pour les
besoins du cinéma
le vrai le film c'est la belle noiseuse
un film marathon de quatre heures tiré
d'une nouvelle de balzac le scénario
raconte l'histoire d'un peintre qui
reprend dix ans après le même tableau
lui c'est piccoli le modèle du tableau
c'est donc emmanuelle béart et
apparemment c'est très réussi
tout le monde a très vite oublié la
bande madonna en portage michel vial
christos camélia concours la croisette
en folie c'était la nuit dernière au
tour de madonna
dix mille personnes assiégeant l'entrée
du palais dans une cohue extérieurs dont
on se souviendra sans doute plus que du
film présenté ensuite le sel c'est une
pro
madonna partie retour à la sélection
officielle avec le troisième film
français en compétition
inspiré librement d'une nouvelle de
balzac la belle noiseuse de jacques
rivette évoque les difficultés de la
création artistique à travers la
relation mystérieuse entre un peintre et
son modèle et connaît le le père prince
bleu
toute façon
si nicolas n'est l'état jusqu'au bout je
le perdrai nous tous quand on pense aux
peintres qui regarde une femme nue et
qui l'a pas on pense tout de suite aux
choses sensuelle érotique ou salaces
c'est pas du tout ça c'est un temps le
cas à travers le secret l'âme de ce
modèle est ce qui va pouvoir trouver son
secret à lui et aussi comment comment ça
bouge quoi comment comment est ce qu'il
faut le casser
présenté à cannes dans une version de
quatre heures le film sortira en salles
réduit de deux heures actuellement en
cours de montage
il sera toutefois aux dires du
réalisateur sensiblement différent de la
version originale